[Music]
I'm Jordan Jordan Robinson oh my god you
really do look like who's she
I'm your aunt Jordan thanks for coming
sure mom would be touched Sophie no no
it's okay I haven't seen your mom in
over 20 years I just miss her so much
it's only got a couple weeks
don't worry I'm not gonna be staying
much longer in your guest room I might
stay in the area though I can talk to
Sharon and HR see if she has any leads
for you just if it's no trouble
happy to Dube what is it what's wrong
bill Carson we got the job my tongue
I don't want you to think that I'm one
of those girls who who goes home with
guys she just met Phil Carson is dead
murdered how are you doing
your mom and I Halloween 1998 this
doesn't look like you though
[Applause]
where's your dad he's upstairs in his
room sure you know what that is you're
sleeping with her aren't you
she is not a member of this family dad
[Music]
okay what are we looking for you know
she's not who you think she is that we
found the real Android she's dead the
fake George killed her
Sophie I know you're in here
you had to go and ruin everything but I
would have made a great mother
you